[Music]
hi everyone
thanks for joining us on the next live
show i'm reto meier and i'm stephanie
wong
if you can't be here in person this week
we've got you covered to make sure you
catch
everything we have six live stream
channels including this one the next
live show
let's kick things off with insights on
this morning's keynote from google cloud
leaders aperna sinha
group product manager kubernetes and
quentin hardy head of editorial great to
see you both
thanks for having us quentin we were
just here together nine months ago
talking about the state of cloud
computing
and that wasn't very long ago what have
you seen that's changed that's cloud
time for you nine months equals a year
and two things stick out one obviously
new leadership we have a new leader at
google cloud and the first keynote is
very telling he's focused on
customer-ready enterprise-ready products
and services and a wealth of them
and customer testimonials backing that
up which is fun to see
the other thing is the products a wealth
of products a year's worth of products
in nine months
i'd like to just cite one of them the
cloud services platform which is now
called anthos
last summer when it was launched it was
prospective it was going to be in alpha
and then beta very rapidly it's
ready in nine months with more features
and products and services within it
then we could imagine having done this
quickly yay to your team
uh and what this allows is for you to
create deploy update
run check secure all these applications
on-prem in google cloud on all the
clouds wherever you want just
take the asset and make it grow and make
it live
better in a system that is open and
secure
and aimed at customer needs now opponent
you've been closely involved in the
creation of the cloud services platform
or
anthos now uh based on what tk's already
shared it already does a lot right but
it's going to do even more
so what will that look like and why
should that matter to our customers
yeah well you know great computing
platforms don't just add features
or you know reduce cost great computing
platforms actually change the game
entirely
they give customers capabilities that
they've not had before
and that's what antho says anthos you
know can be used even if you're not
in the cloud so it can be used in your
on-prem data center
to give you a cloud-like environment
cloud-like agility and speed
but also cloud-like control and
centralized
risk management and it gives both your
operators and your
developers a level of visibility
operational visibility as well as ease
of use for the developer
that is hard to find anywhere else and
then if you do decide that you're going
to
use a public cloud anthos gives you what
no one else gives you
which is choice and it allows you to
write once and deploy your services
anywhere
and that's you know what really
accelerates your business success
the reason we like open systems yes it's
a better way to make more secure
software
it's better choice you get more velocity
these are all great advantages
there's an element of self-interest here
too though by leaving it up to the
customer by giving them that freedom and
choice
it compels us to stay competitive we
have to listen more closely we have to
respond
more quickly and if you have locked in
customers it's kind of a recipe for
mediocrity
you know i think one of the things that
a lot of customers
like about the cloud is that they don't
have to worry about
all of the things you know they can
focus on the things that are important
to them
and things that add value to their
business so for example
developers and engineers can focus on
differentiated capabilities that are
unique and the cloud takes
care of all the rest but why only in the
cloud
you know this is something that you
ought to be able to do on-prem as well
and that's what anthos does it dissolves
the layers that are underneath the
differentiating pieces
and those are managed by cloud by google
cloud or they're managed automatically
and that way you know your business can
focus on
accelerating itself right it seems like
it's picking the workloads that make
sense for our customers
quentin you mentioned before we started
that modernizing and migrating was
another big keynote takeaway
how does google cloud's integration with
and migration of enterprise systems help
our customers
exactly what aparna was just saying why
can't it do more
and in this case why can't your data do
more why can't all that
hard work that people established over
decades learning their customers
learning their market learning their
products
be taken to the cloud or be empowered
inside on-prem systems
and get new life get new power find new
insights
with ml and ai or by employing
other cloud services just refreshing all
that and taking that legacy
and using that as an insight to move
into the future speaking of this focus
on our users quentin what do you think
are some of the most compelling examples
of learnings that come with working with
our customers you know what's easy to do
in tech
deliver a lot of complexity and com some
companies love complexity because it's
kind of like lock-in
if you can get somebody to learn all
that complexity they'll never learn
anything else they'll be afraid
you know what's hard simplicity
simplicity on the back end
for the provider is really tough because
you got to consider a lot of use cases
you got to build in a way that's going
to work for a lot of different interests
and people and locations
that requires a lot of careful thought
and you've got to have a kind of empathy
for what the customer wants to do what
does the customer want to do
the customer wants to do the things it's
good at the customer he or she
wants to proceed with the things they've
learned in the market with the products
they're passionate about
that might not actually be container
management that's something we're
passionate about that's something we do
and in some ways
this is economics 101 let everybody
focus on their comparative advantage
we are freeing up customers we are
giving them that simplicity
so they can get stuff out of the way and
just work on the problems to serve their
customers
now opener quentin's been talking a lot
about business folks but what does this
mean for the operators and the
developers who are going to be using
this technology
yeah well like i said it's a game
changer for the
operators and the developers i would say
there's three kind of big changes
number one is the right ones deploy
anywhere
for developers it means that you can
focus
on the things that add differentiation
to your business
for the cio it means actually that you
can really concentrate your talent you
don't fragment your talent across
multiple different
code bases around across multiple
different types of tools
and if you think about it you know every
customer i've talked to always says
the talent is the most scarce resource
particularly engineering talent is
really hard to hire
it's really hard to you know keep the
talent motivated
and i think the reason creators are
excited about anthos is again for the
same reasons right
because they also get access to a
multi-cloud platform
they also get access to the benefits of
something that's
um you know at a level that they can
differentiate their code and don't have
to worry about the underlying
you know infrastructure pieces quentin
google ceo sundar pachai
was an important part of the day one
keynote as well what did his presence
say about um
how google sees the cloud industry uh
well
obviously you bring out the ceo of
google
he's putting the stamp on it that this
is big and you can't say that enough and
this gets
kind of to an abstract reality of where
we are right now in the world
there are four major players five
you could go to six five to ten billion
in capex each
this is a very big stakes operation
because
this is the infrastructure of the future
as much as you think about
airports or highways or deep water ports
or telephones and telegraphs in their
time this
is the infrastructure of the future that
we are building
and our competitors are building we're
building it with a certain spirit we've
talked about today
we think will give the customers the
most power give
individuals of any size a small company
large company
freelancer you name it greater energy
greater power greater freedom
to realize what they want to do in the
world thank you so much for joining us
again and sharing your insights it's
great to be here thank you
thanks for having us
[Music]
you